[Musique]
alexandre dubard 1802 1870 un auteur
française bien connue bien célèbre il
fit des trois mousquetaires athos
porthos et aramis et de leurs cannelle
jeune d'artagnan des héros de légende
ils sont universelles et immortel mais
ce que l'on sait moins c'est
qu'alexandre dumas était un fin gourmet
on lui doit un dictionnaire de cuisine
un ouvrage considérable avec des
dizaines devenu et quel menu et des
milliers recettes en lisant on rêve on
rêvait nous avons rêvé nous avons
imaginé et nous vous invitons à imaginer
avec nous imaginons que d'artagnan est
encore à paris il a beaucoup fait rire
beaucoup guerroyer beaucoup courtisé et
bien sûr beaucoup aimé et il est las de
la vie parisienne et des intrigues de la
cour ira de revenir dans son bon pays
basque à parcourir avec les
mousquetaires les colis de gascogne
respirer les parfums de la glace de la
campagne goûter la bonne cuisine
gasconne y retrouver au coin du feu
une bonne maïté qui l'attend ma fsi
d'artagnan arrivait qu'est ce que vous
lui feriez on va commencer par les fans
beauregard bury une bonne s'inquiète
avec des bus en lardons persillade un
bon foie gras il choisira il ya
plusieurs façons de le faire un bon
confie avec des pommes de terre sautées
ou alors non du mak rire de le faire les
bons magrets grillés avec la peau ce
veilleur quelques scènes bien à la
persillade et on verra la suite à ce qui
demandera et vous savez pour commencer
ça bouge là dedans qu'est-ce que vous
avez le monde canard pour faire tout ça
camara regardez comme il ajouté
un bon petit canard mon petit canard
viens de lire votre petit canard ni
d'iodé mort il est gros il est beau et
magnifique milliard en petit nid
allemande côté on va lancer le premier
problème de twitts canada n'est pas
malade puis ils vont pas le truc on va
le mettre ici via un appel à un plat
bien voilà voilà voilà voilà
on est là pour le paquet ce match parce
qu'autrement cible automne et où les
elles vont se marcher le confie moins de
bon tandis que là il peut se débattre il
ne bouge pas on ne sait il ne souffre
pas et c'est impeccable
vous allez voir ça et même très bien
alors on va le faire tout de suite ça
tout de suite première opération
voilà nous avons là et on a enseigné
comment fait bien chez doit alors nous
avons recueilli le son vous alliez ces
petites réparations et j'imagine que
selon quoi faire une recette présentiel
c'est sur d'artagnan les mousquetaires
ont dû connaître c'est lassant 4,64
pour cela vous devez préparer je crois à
la lance quelques ingrédients là on a
fait de bonnes persillade
voilà eh bien à couper de la ventrèche
durablement
voilà un tout petit morceau que l'on met
alors feu mais un peu de sel au fond du
plat la persillade et la ventrèche
pendant la paire 6 ans avant d'en suivre
la rentrée chat j'ai saigné le canard et
maintenant voilà c'est le cuir et vous
allez recueilli le sang tout frais tout
près de vous ferez tout fait tout près
en agressant un petit votre soirée
cadrant pas que ce soit très sérieuse en
prière assis dos de cuillère sauterait
grèce nous allons laisser chauffer la
poêle bien chaude parce que c'est quand
même un meilleur la cuisine à la grèce
mais d'abord légales et canard ou d'oie
que lui il a quand même oui voilà là
c'était même pas tout à fait assez chaud
mais enfin ça va bien maintenant on va
mettre ça à laver à matane moyens que ça
chauffe
voilà tout simplement comme une galette
andy ram avec viande bio bien sûr et
après on va la coupe est un petit peu et
là je crois qu'il faut mettre un local
fini de cuir on pourrait peut-être foncé
à notre canard parce qu'il faut
l'allonger allumé le saint louis et
alors que le mali ne fait voile qui a
plusieurs techniques
moi j'ai toujours du plus mais les
canards c'est une catastrophe pour nous
mettre à la cuisine
pas du tout on est pas du tout pas du
tout comme vous faites vous avant une
recette à nouveau comme non dans les
landes il ya de la résignation et nous
avons ceci ça s'appelle la résine à
sévère résine sèche nous brisons cette
résine ou la météo en poussière sous la
brise indien nous prenons notre canard
je vais vous montrer la résine ne pas
briser ma ferme à la briser nous fondons
notre canard portant que pauvre petit
vélo comme tous qu'il est beau mon fils
de [ __ ] et un ace elle devrait convier
de voilà pour ceux qui l'auront 600 kg
2006 qui doit alors on fera la résine ou
bien voudrait bien fine aux normes et
sur le canal
quand mes liens dans les primes comme ça
c'est très facile mais surtout surtout
ce qu'il faut faire c'est un mec bien
dans la tête voilà qui est bien bien
parce que là peut-être ce sujet serait
plus qu'ils sont beaucoup plus durs a
appuyé à vue mais alors s'applique bien
bien bien affronter bien avec la presse
affaires ça comme une évidence et une
commune chemise et on va regarder le
canard les parcs d'abord parce qu'on
voit aux bars silhouette impeccable
il faut que les pattes de canards se
faire tout seul voit on veut et on
relèvera
voilà alors là vous pourrez regarder ça
elle fait calme tenez voilà regarder sas
hotel tous ça veut dire que l'on est à
80 degrés ça se fait voilà il nous
allons reprendre le canard
nous allons commencer par les stades
encore le fort royal un petit salon le
relever pour parler comme il est très
gros pour replonger l'autre moitié
voilà nous allons pousser tout ceci et
je vous montrerai le bre comment ça fait
quoi
vous prenez et s'appelle tout seul corps
une chemise voilà voyez pourquoi c'est
le vrai voilà donc une plume c'est
magnifique que je vais être que je
brouille et tout nuit là et puis nous
voulons faire des malgré alors voilà qui
coupe et on va couper sa est la couleur
de la peau si j'achète un canard tout
près tous plus mais il faut que l'apôtre
comme celle à priori très doré très
blanche
ça veut dire qu'il a été pris au maïs
élevé qu'aux maïs est bien soigné et
beaucoup de verdure à un canard de
manger beaucoup de verdure pour faire un
beau jabot
logiquement il faudrait traiter deux
fois d'abord parce qu'au fond et
présentons premier à l'enlever en
premiers mois nous avons déjà une
prochaine fois on avoue des coupes et si
on peut dire le long de la côte est
vraiment là
on vient délicatement
les magrets petit à petit il acquis sur
le côté voilà le mal
maïté cemagref on va décrire comme un
voile a sauvé grid
on va commencer dans l'écouté on les
retourne tous les deux maintenant on les
coupe en deux parce que je laisse là
pour ce meilleur c'est bien meilleur
alors voilà vous plaît comme ceci vous
le mettez de côté
vous leur mettez bien droit pour leur
couper mais sans aller jusqu'aux formes
voyez là six races isolé et pourquoi les
médecins parce que sur le plat ça va
vous faire un très joli et nous allons
faire dans la peau pour ne pas que la
peau se recroqueville
voilà là et là regardez comment vous
avez un joli morceau de viande et nous
nous mettons sur le feu alors notre
breizh ont naturellement préparer à ces
halles avant de vouloir en cheminée et
le grill un petit peu au dessus de ce
soit vraiment pas où à l'ouest les
braises bien au dessus voilà la fois la
cuisson va nous prendre à peu près
combien de temps on veut pas dire pas
longtemps parce que de mal gré il faut
pas qu'ils soient secs
il faut pas qu'il soit en plus on le
voit on voit la fourchette
on ne voit ça ça ça paraît nous allons
le salé le poivre et au département
d'état où après un vol entre les dents
sur le temple un peu et particules
pourrions peut-être vers juste quelques
pommes de terre pour l'accompagner dans
la graisse du canal où les sales europe
après pas dans la grèce nous remettrons
la persillade qui restait de l'abn
s'inquiète
c'est à dire un petit mélange de persil
et la neige est très haché tresserre ils
vont pas trop vite non maghreb ancien
valet tourner où qu'ils nous ils sont
ponctuées sont merveilleusement bien
vous quand vous dites qu'il n'est pas
assez cuit c'est facile est encore trop
trop rose et blanc regarder hélas très
bon il faut quand on va l'offrir qu'ils
soient roses de dons et croustillant les
gêneurs légèrement légèrement faut pas
dire seigneur mais légèrement d'ici là
il est impeccable
oui là il est magnifique avec ce qu'il
appelle à la couleur c'est encore un
petit peu
nassau nos pommes de terre sont
magnifiques
ça ne sont superbes voilà tout va être
pris en même temps nous malgré son prix
il sent juste à point au kiss tour burj
oki son jour j voilà je vais les mettre
là je vais sortir les pommes de terrain
elle semble bel et bien dorée elle somme
magnifique la retiennent doré je vais
salle et les poivrer les persillé voilà
saler poivrer et la bonne persillade
je vais remuer le tout
enfin bon c'est extra sur lie c'est bien
la conte et ça ça va en sommes voilà
voilà et bien réalité alors je vous
souhaite à mon habitude nous souhaitons
un bon appétit et nous allons marcher ça
avec un bon petit bordeaux avec un bon
petit rouge ou après tout nous sommes en
armagnac avec un peu de jus en sont
peut-être à la réalité aujourd'hui on
some région
nous avons pris un canard vous nous avez
appris à l'enseigné de manière à ce
qu'ils ne soient pas blessés parce que
une hémorragie interne à vivre et nos
formes ici nous reparlerons
vous nous avez appris comment le plus
mais sur l'abîmé
grâce à la résine et ensuite on a trempé
dans le chaudron tout est parti d'un
second sans abîmer notre canard avec le
son que nous avons recueillies vous avez
montré comment ça une sans kate elle est
là la sanquette serre que vous aviez
préparé une petite persillade loin
devant persil ail et ce qu'on appelle
dans toute la france des arts d'eau et
en gascogne de l'avant première approche
et puis on a fait pire ça dans de la
graisse de canard les deux faces comme
une crêpe
ensuite nous avons découpé les
maquerelles nous avait montré comment il
fallait enlever la chemise vous avez dit
jacques est comme ça de notre canard
pour découper les magrin qu'on a perdus
au milieu on a ouvert on leur a bien
laissé leur graisse
parce que ça amène du mois le voilà on
les a mis sur une braise pas trop chaude
on a surveillé pour qu'il soit bien
grillé mais bien rose là on le voit bien
roses interviennent pas très satisfait
ce sera juteux quand on va le marché
ça c'est sûr et puis nous avons préparé
donc des pommes de terre et cordiale
pour les accompagner et bien notre
prochain rendez vous mettez vous
les nous apprendre à traiter les foies
de mille et une manières il ya beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de manières de faire
le foie gras et c'est délicieux
toutes sont très bonnes toutes les
recettes sont extras et bien une fois
nous irons chercher nos fois dans nos
bons canards gras voile et nous verrons
quelle que manière de les traiter à la
gasconne voilà
[Musique]